[Music]  i don't consider myself a particularly  ethical person  but i'm fair  kochi  it was a name that sounded so sweet so  seductive god meet the family everybody  this is patricia and this is my family  they had it all  worth style  power who wouldn't care for that  [Music]  my nephew i have been a gucci all my  life  it is an empire  you can help the family which is not  exciting and everybody knows it at least  it's my name sweetie  our name  sweetie  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  this is not the woman's game  remember that  madness who sitting here  it's time to take out the trash  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  don't  miss  [Music]  [Applause]  i don't consider myself a particularly  ethical person no but i am fair  i subscribe to  unconventional punishments  [Music]  you